Eh
f
[music]
Go to me
Wearing clothes like my father Hey, I've
experienced actual combat on the tip of the wire
If I was stronger, I might not have been hurt in March
What's with the
whining?
When I was my age, I
must have done a lot more amazing missions I hope you
'll envy
me Because there were a lot of tough missions in our time
And
I lost my friends on missions
Surrounded by people who are important to me  I envy you more, but I
can't choose the era in which I was born Instead
of worrying about such things,
I should think about what I can do now
[Music] To
escape I
[Music]
Big brother, do your best, go around the
house
There are people who think of
you  I'm not alone Tori
soy sauce
I'll do what I can masa